you think I can't beat this is the game
oh how many times have I died oh oh
that's right he hasn't died oh oh look
at it look at him he's doing it
perfectly I wonder how it's not like
I've done this a million [ __ ] times
by now oh you cheeky
chip bear on me can you [ __ ] off if you
think this game is hard then I tell you
what you might want to check your
priveledge there buddy if this game was
life this game would be straight white
male oh [ __ ]
[Music]
now let's go to the [ __ ] place where
dreams are dying dead dreams die here oh
look mr. orange we meet again goodbye
goodbye mr. orange goodbye oh Jesus this
bit sucks so [ __ ] much I'm legit just
sick of it
[Music]
seesee that was not easy
you [ __ ] idiot listen to me okay all
right watch this
easy I'm out of mouse space what the
[ __ ] do I do
stop you've no do I need a hanger ship
for my mousepad I ran out of space what
do I do
[Music]
what the [ __ ] mouse I'm adding an extra
because this is ridiculous this mountain
makes no sense by the way thank you you
know what [ __ ] off pace get me back up
stop sliding please okay double mouse
strap clearly doesn't work okay slow
slow slow
oh god stop I don't know how people do
this bin I just don't understand it I
keep sliding down no matter what I do
and I don't have that big of a mouse mat
I'm sorry so I'm gonna have to go with
the beard stripe stripe doesn't work now
I'll keep falling I don't care razor you
make the worst [ __ ] mouse pad I've
ever seen
how can you [ __ ] up a mouse pad it's not
that [ __ ] hard this [ __ ] bit
can suck my [ __ ] pain keep falling
keep falling I dare you oh wow Wow
everybody
he did it he did it yeah but he's not a
good day hey go away Edgar oh okay all
right I get it
oh it's gonna be hard now because you
but [ __ ] off easy
hey a little thumbs up isn't that cute
oh now now it's when the game really
gets hard pears
now it's when to break up thank you
thumbs up thank you I think I'm actually
stuck with it oh wow that is a tiny
little thumb you try to scare me but I
don't get scared ever not sure how to do
this bit but I don't care Oh No hey hey
hey hey thumbs what the [ __ ] was that oh
this time is gonna be easy I done it
once before to be easy to do it again
man yeah boy I'm comin up I want the
world to know you gotta let it show come
in Jamie
[Music]
Hey
all right what once seemed impossible is
now extremely doable just like your
mother
haha hey tiger listen here ain't got
time for you while making this game how
can we make that can we make it steeper
please let's make it steeper hello
mister thumb we meet again it's been
written mrs. M why did you do that that
is just stupid keep falling I [ __ ]
dare you you know what you know what see
if I give her she keep phone you think I
care you think I [ __ ] care take me
back take me back all the way
damn it Oh
oh no I keep shut I'm back baby oh you
thought I was gonna go away did ya you
thought I was gonna [ __ ] go what Duff
that's fine not a big deal at all
no you messed that [ __ ] [ __ ] up
getting a little sweaty now come on
[ __ ] what you got huh what you got
there show me this show me what you got
oh my god
you like Happy Meals on McDonald's oh I
bet you do
hey guys sit the [ __ ] still like I'm a
nothing distractions [ __ ] do you like
Happy Meals on McDonagh
Wow ah listen here I don't care you need
to go you need to go Edgar you need to
go I'm not your dad
[ __ ] off okay I don't have to pay child
services for more whatever the [ __ ] this
bit sucks so much and that I could
become a titty dispenser you know I'm
saying grab the rock move it slow no no
no no no no no no it is fine
you try again little pudy pie just try
again my foodie friend oh you've done
this many times you can do it again you
can do it again punch just believe you
got your friends don't waiting for you
to do it oh come on pulse please we want
you to listen please just do the thing
oh I'm doing it I'm right of mouse space
I'm out of my eyes I am Li not joking I
am at the edge of them but I'm at you
I'm using my hand now oh it does know
what oh now this I'm so sick of it
oh no no no no I'm not just some casual
little youtuber who's like oh the gamer
very hard oh I feel so angry well cuz
the game is a little much like having
I'm here stirred so I don't I'm so angry
what do you mean no no no no no I didn't
mean
letting me enemy mean betting me betting
me okay all right everybody don't go too
slow cuz you'll run out of mouse space
oh oh my my my - my space I'm out of my
space I'm not joking I'm not joking put
it down put it down put it down put it
down put a dam put a dam but a dam
pretend pretend but a temple of them oh
how nice everybody
oh he's killing it everybody we're
watching live very paid okay Wow Greg's
great commentary coming from Perry PI he
does this for a living he says Wow
incredible hello little Carrie kuru Kara
alright you want some of this alright
don't extend your arm okay do not extend
your arms go [ __ ] yourself out and
that's what he wants you to do do not do
it do not do what he wants you to do oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah careful there buddy
hey you being be real hey you gotta be
[ __ ] you huh how about that [ __ ] you do
not extend do not extend your arm Felix
ay ay ay ay mr. pussycat you wanna
nanana Nana fem
you're leaning the wrong way oh no no no
there you go a ohms
do not extend do not extend catch it
catch it catch it easy oh you thought I
would die oh no no do not extend the arm
don't extend suck a dick oh don't even
[ __ ] try to do that don't extend the
[ __ ] arm hey mister tummy oh that's
gonna push me down isn't it oh okay okay
okay okay everybody okay huh you think
this is funny